when you were dating Emilio Estevez when  you were shooting st. Elmo's fire and  you said oh I found some family Emilio  was nice enough to bring you to meet his  brother Charlie Sheen you got to see  Martin Sheen as a father I get why you  kind of fell in love with this guy yeah  he was shooting a movie with him st.  Elmo's fire but when he brings you to  his house and he's got a semi-normal  family you're like this is the greatest  thing ever you probably more in love  with the family than you were with  Emilio I mean the whole the whole thing  was definitely like intoxicating yeah  because it it was an exceeding something  that was very clearly different than  what I had and seeing how they were  these formidable figures you know  parental figures and that they had  influence and guidance or you could and  and I just really appreciated I really  appreciated how they were